pendant le confinement les filles en
matière de tâches ménagères
si vous voulez la parité faites comme
moi instauré le mariage à point ces
mariages à point non c'est moi qui l'aï
inventé c'est comme le permis un point
vous donner un capital de 12 points à
votre mari si vous saoule
il perd des points quand il a plus de
points ils dégagent par exemple s'il
fait un délit de fuite devant la
vaisselle à faire c'est deux points en
moins utilisation du téléphone portable
pendant qu on fait l'amour c'est quatre
points mois siaka mais son kit main
libre utilisation exagérément prolongée
des toilettes six points en moins je ne
comprends pas que vous passiez autant de
temps dans les wc les gars moi au début
je croyais qu'il avait creusé un tunnel
qui conduit directement au bistrot du
coin donc désormais à la maison les
toilettes c'est une zone bleue j'ai
installé le système du disque avec art
d'entrée et heures de sorties
obligatoires
donc c'est six points en moins c'est
sévère mais attention il peut récupérer
des points
en suivant des stages de sensibilisation
à la gente féminine
bien sûr ce sont des stages payants qui
ont lieu chez vuitton et quartier un sac
vuitton sti récupère trois points une
bague cartier site wap voyez c'est ça le
mariage à point alors je tiens à dire
n'allez pas penser que c'est un sketch
féministe d'ailleurs je crois que suis
pas très doué pour pour parler de
féminisme et et jouer la féministe et
dans un monde qui a envie de voir les
femmes émancipées
la question se pose suis-je trop
masculine attention j'ai conscience que
le féminisme c'est très important
c'est une visite surveillance par
exemple quand un artiste écrit une
chanson en hommage aux femmes libérées
ça permet lui dire écoute cookies elle
est sympa ta chanson ça part d'un bon
sentiment et c'est très maladroit mais
savoir d'un bon sentiment
c'est très très maladroit
ne laisse pas tomber elle est si fragile
être une femme libérée
tu sais c'est pas si facile attention
hommage sa première vie d'un coup lui
fais du souci l'europe c'est du miroir
sur sa vie elle rares 120 à chaque fois
qu'elle sort maintenant elles vivent
disent qu'il faut faire un des femmes
écoutez bien ce sens du compliment
cookie dingler moi si je peux faire des
chansons en hommage aux hommes
sa calvitie pu faire du souci son goût
bidan baez sur sa piste
dans le genre très très maladroit avec
les femmes il ya orelsan
alors lui faut le surveiller sinon il
écrit des trucs comme les féminismes
persécute peu près le pompeux et ses
buts
comme si c'était de ma faute si les mavs
ses députés c'est très très malade la
première fois que j'ai entendu cette
chanson j'ai tout de suite pensé à la
maman noël san luis cabral sanaa une
maman évidemment et le métier de sa
maman ses institutrices
il a aussi un papa dont le métier est
directeur d'école jure que c'est vrai
alors qu'est ce qui s'est passé dans sa
maman a entendu cette chanson à la radio
allo aurélien oui aurélien c'est maman
dis donc en rien qu'est ce que je viens
d'entendre à la radio là les meufs ses
députés
non je ne veux pas que tes explications
aurélien n'y a rien à expliquer les
meufs ses débuts tenons les meufs sont
des [ __ ] oui le verbe s'accordent avec
le sujet aurait bien c'est du niveau co2
pardon tu es une victoire de la musique
pour cet album bien moi je te décerne
une défaite de l'orthographe
[Musique]
estelle soleil c'est merci
oui
[Applaudissements]